left-hander nick margavichus is going
through his warm-up tosses getting ready
for his second start
of the season nick owen won on the start
of the year
nick looking to take care of the astros
this afternoon
leading things off for the astros it'll
be right fielder kyle tucker
the wind up and again the two two swung
on one hopper to the shortstop
kyle seeger that's kyle seeger playing
short with a shift on
he's got it throws the first and it's in
time to get tucker and there's one away
and here is first baseman yuli guriel
and the booze continue to rain down for
the
astros dwight three called got him
looking with a fastball dots the outside
corner at the knees
strikeout number one for nick
margavichus
and that'll bring up designated hitter
today michael brantley
now he gets brantley with a swing and a
miss for strike three back-to-back
strikeouts for
nick vargavich's jayco touristy on the
mound for houston making his second
start in an astros uniform
he makes his first road start of the
season in an astros uniform will be
mitch hanniker starting things off for
seattle this one hit slowly at the third
base line and that is a fair ball
and played by oled miss diaz over to
first in time to get mitch henniger
nicely done by litmus
so one out and the batter will be the
designated hitter tai
france down and away a breaking ball for
ball four
so ty france with a one-out walk the
mariners have one on
and here is third baseman kyle seeger
tried to hold up
and he goes around and that is a
strikeout for odor rizzy and that is
number one thousand
in jake odorizzi's career so
congratulations to him that's a good
number
yeah it is one on two outs and here is
left fielder jose marmaleon
inside ball court so a couple of walks
given up by oda rizzy
now the mariners have runners on it
first and second with two outs and
that'll bring up first baseman evan
white
he's on a roll three-game hitting streak
four for his last nine
swinging a fly ball into shallow right
center field straw racing in can't get
to it it's going to drop in a basement
france will score seven white with a
bloop single the mariners
have a one to nothing lead mariners now
have runners on it first and third with
two outs
and that will bring up second baseman
dylan moore
swinging and a miss got him on a high
fastball boar angrily throws down his
bat and slams down his helmet because he
knows he swung
at a ball but second strikeout go to
rizzy
so quite the sequence there for seattle
and ever and then on the very next pitch
a wild pitch
so the astros just like that have the
tying run in scoring position
that'll bring up third baseman led miss
neons and diaz
crushes one deep to left center field
back on it is marmillo's fighting the
sun
he can't see it it hits on the warning
track and bounces over the wall
correa will score into second base goes
diaz with an rbi
double to make it a one-one game astros
you've got to take advantage of mistakes
mariners and the astros now tied at one
jake odorizzi
back at it one out for the mariners here
now the one-two
swinging and a miss got him on a high
fastball third strikeout voter rizi two
out
now it's jp crawford's turn swinging and
a mess got him on the high fastball
jake odorisi needed a quick inning and
he got it just nine pitches strikes out
a pair
two outs for julie guriel sets up inside
here's the pitch he swings
jams him pops it up foul ground first
base side white is over murphy as well
evan white is able to slide down to his
right hip
and make the catch on the warning track
right in front of the mariners dugout
phenomenal play by the gold glover at
first base
odorizzi settled down and only 59
pitches through three innings after 37
in the first inning alone gave up the
one run it's 1-1
jose marmalejos lays things up as ball
up in the zone swinging to miss odor
rizzy has
five strikeouts today against marmalajos
how about
jayco to rizzy all of a sudden locked in
has retired nine in a row
and has six strikeouts three two pitch
foul tip caught by castro and odor rizzi
has struck out the side getting
marmalajo's white and dylan moore
he is sent down 10 in a row trainer for
the mariners out to check up on
margavitches along with manager scott
service nick margaret just has to leave
the ball game and lj newsom
has come on here good base running by
chaz mccormick
and now he's 90 feet away with the
go-ahead run and only one out
miles straw at the plate straw lifts
this out on the right backs up hannah
gets behind it makes the catch mccormick
tax he will
score and the astros lead it 2-1 on the
sac fly by strong
and now the mariners have runners on it
first and second with
one away this is early in jake odersi's
career
with the astros this is a really big
spot for him to try and get through this
fifth inning
and the battery is mitch haniger legit
threat here by the mariners swinging a
fly ball to the center field
backing up backing up straw to the
warning track still going back reaches
out and it's off his glove in the fifth
inning
around to third base with a two-run
triple and jacob derisi's day is going
to end after four and a third innings
and brooks raley is the new pitcher on
the mound the left-hander to face ty
france healthy fly ball the mariners
pick up another run
that'll do it high flying ball deep left
way back way back home
the mariners have now scored four here
in the bottom of the fifth
igoti is into second and castro hit by
the pitch is at first
tying run is now at the plate kyle
tucker with four home runs this year
they did
that will do it the threat ends right
there
first down murphy at first base after
the lead off walk here comes mitch
haniger here's a drive deep to left
that's gonna get down
bounce up against the fence murphy
getting a wave off coming around
third here's the throw to the plate he
is in there safely
and rbi double in the mariners lead it's
now six to two
here's
another big loud knock three rbis for
him today
the mariners have a 7-2 lead here in the
seventh peter solomon now on the pitch
for the astros making his major league
debut
24 years old native of elkhot ellicott
city maryland 1-2
popped it up on the infield solomon
coming in castro going out they're going
to be called off by diaz who makes the
catch
on the grass in front of the pitcher's
mound and the inning draws to a close
more a one-out walk but peter solomon's
first big league inning is scoreless
big right-hander drew steckenrider will
take over in relief
to get the final three outs in this one
brown ball the white at first he's got
it
underhand flipped the second rider at
the bag and the mariners won it seven to
two this afternoon
over the astros and the mariners win the
series
two games the one three consecutive
series win
for the mariners